a
été jugé. Vous étiez parmi les
diplomates étrangers. Vous avez
dit que ça n'a pas de bon sens.
Vous première réaction?
- Ma première réaction a été une
réaction de joie évidemment pour
les deux Michael. Mes deux
furies en un endroit de la
Chine. On démontrait ce que la
Chine niait depuis toujours.
C'est-à-dire que les deux
Michael avaient été arrêtés
strictement en représailles. Que
c'était un dossier de ce que
l'on appelle diplomatie des
otages. Alors la Chine qui parle
de la grande coopération
internationale, elle confirmait
dans ce geste, en laissant aller
les deux Michael, qui ont été la
que pour une affaire d'otages
dans une mésentente avec les
États-Unis.
- Qu'est-ce que ça vous dit sur
le poids de l'administration de
Joe Biden.
Ils ont demandé les deux Michael
dans un avion à la même heure de
la libération de Meng Wanzhou.
Comment interpréter cela.
- Il y a un problème majeur de
relations entre la Chine et les
États-Unis.
Probablement qu'effectivement,
il y a eu un poids énorme qui a
été exercé par l'administration
américaine pose que cette
histoire se résolve à l'avantage
des deux parties. Pour les
Américains, ce qui était
important, c'était que Meng
Wanzhou reconnaît ses torts.
Mais il faut parler du rôle
important de l'ambassadeur
canadien à Pékin. Au printemps,
il a passé trois semaines à
Washington avec sa collègue
ambassadrice du Canada à
Washington à négocier avec
l'administration américaine, la
Maison-Blanche. Dès que Joe
Biden est arrivé au pouvoir. De
nouvelles discussions avaient
commencé. C'est l'un des
personnages dans le monde des
affaires avant qu'il entend
diplomatie qui avait le plus
gros réseau de contacts dans le
monde. Son rôle a été discret
mais important. Les Chinois
savaient que jouer un rôle dans
cette négociation. Pas question
pour ce monsieur que tout cela
se règle sans qu'il y ait une
garantie de libération pour les
deux Michael. Ce qui m'a étonné,
c'est que je pensais
personnellement, on savait que
ça s'envenimait, mais je me
disais que les Chinois vont
attendre quelque temps avant de
libérer les deux Michael pour
continuer ce mythe des
accusations d'espionnage. Et
faire un échange de prisonniers.
Mais le fait qu'ils aient été
libérés immédiatement, qui sois
arrivé au Canada avec
l'ambassadeur dans l'avion, dans
le jet privé, cela confirme que
les Chinois n'avaient cette
valeur en main que pour négocier
la libération de Meng Wanzhou.
Si cette pratique devait
continuer, de la part d'un État
qui se prétend une grande
puissance, c'est extrêmement
dangereux. C'est extrêmement
dangereux. On ne peut pas entre
pays responsables utilisés des
moyens comme cela pour régler
des différends. Pour moi, c'est
ce qu'il y a de plus fondamental
dans ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui. Malheureusement,
les deux Michael auront souffert
terriblement pour que l'on
découvre en fait qu'ils avaient
été pris simplement en otage
dans une affaire commerciale et
judiciaire.
- Comment voir l'avenir de tous
les Québécois et Canadiens qui
font des affaires en Chine?
C'est un partenaire commercial
important. Qu'est-ce que cela
vous dit sur l'avenir des
relations?
- Il va falloir poser de
sérieuses questions ou Chinois.
En faisant l'échange, ils ont
admis qu'il y avait une
négociation par voie d'otages.
C'est énorme. Si on laisse cela
sans conséquence, à mon avis, ça
risque de continuer en Chine et
dans d'autres pays. Parce que
les Chinois, on n'a pas
l'impression peut-être quand on
regarde la Chine de l'extérieur,
mais la Chine est très écoutée
dans le monde. J'arrive
d'Égypte. La Chine est un modèle
en Égypte. L'Égypte est en train
de se développer à une vitesse
absolument folle. Sur le modèle
chinois. Si les Chinois se
permettre d'avouer publiquement
qu'ils ont enlevé ces deux
personnes simplement pour mettre
de la pression, imaginez, tous
les dangers qui vont surgir
partout dans le monde. Peut-être
que le public ne se souvient pas
de l'époque au Liban par exemple
les Américains et les Français,
tout le monde était présent au
Liban. Il y avait des
enlèvements d'otages presque
tous les jours. Les groupes
terroristes négociaient par
enlèvement d'otages. On pensait
que c'était une époque révolue.
Mais non. Et c'est extrêmement
grave de la part du pouvoir
chinois.
- Joe Biden à négocier
extrêmement fort. Est-ce que
cela ne vous dit pas qu'il peut
faire contrepoids et que les
Chinois il y a quand même une
limite qui ne peuvent pas
dépasser. Ou bien dans votre
esprit, il n'y a plus beaucoup
de limites.
- Je pense que les Chinois
avaient absolument besoin de
réduire les différents avec la
première puissance mondiale, les
États-Unis. Cette affaire embête
et tout le monde.
La Chine a accepté que des
négociations semaines dans le
sens qui est arrivé.
Parce que ce n'est pas...
j'ai entendu votre invité un peu
plus tôt. Les Chinois savent
qu'il y avait deux otages
canadiens. Il savait qu'ils
étaient accusés d'espionnage et
de trahison.
Nous étions interpellés dans la
rue sur ce sujet. Mais vous le
voyez aujourd'hui, la Chine
parle très peu de la libération
des deux Canadiens. Parce que
les Chinois ne sont pas fiés de
cela. C'est une concession
difficile qu'ils ont dû faire.
En même temps, c'est une
concession qui illustre cette
situation absolument
invraisemblable que l'on a
utilisée des otages pour
négocier un règlement
diplomatique avec les États-
Unis. Donc c'est une situation,
les Chinois ne sont pas fiers
de cela. Les États-Unis avaient
besoin de la reconnaissance de
la part de Huawei
pour pouvoir après cela imposer
d'autres mesures.
- C'est une petite tape sur les
doigts. Il y a une sortie de
crise.
Jean-François, je reviens à ce
que vous faisiez en Chine. Vous
connaissez bien vous aimer la
Chine. Est-ce que les hommes
d'affaires ont peur?
La Chine se durcit
politiquement?
- Tout à fait. De plus en plus
de gens ont peur d'aller en
Chine. J'essaie quand même de
convaincre les gens que si on ne
fait pas d'erreur sur le plan de
la justice, si on fait des
affaires honnêtement et de façon
transparente, il y a une
certaine sécurité en Chine. Mais
au moment où je dis cela, et je
dis cela au public canadien et
québécois, je me dis que c'est
invraisemblable ce que l'on
vient d'apprendre. Les Chinois
reconnaissent cela. Ça peut être
un exemple qui sera suivi dans
d'autres pays. Au moment où l'on
se parle, je connais un homme
d'affaires québécois qui est
pris en Chine dans un différend
judiciaire. Il ne peut pas
sortir du pays. Il est
prisonnier à l'intérieur de la
Chine. Même l'ambassade et les
diplomates canadiens ne peuvent
pas toucher à cela tellement
c'est délicat. Il y a des choses
comme cela qui se passe. Donc
dans quel contexte, c'est le
contexte où tout le différend
commercial se produit n'est pas
clair. C'est le problème à la
fois de l'homme d'affaires
canadien et de ses anciens
partenaires Chinois. Mais
lorsqu'on est droit en affaires,
en principe, on ne